ils sont huit versailles et et viennent
de remporter la france a un incroyable
talent la famille lefebvre est entré
dans le coeur des français et du jury
avec leur musique sacrée en fait on a
été repéré par la prod qui nous a
contactés ce que nous on ne l'a jamais
eu l'idée d'aller là bas ça nous
paraissait un peu décalé faire de la
musique sacrée et sur m6 à la prime time
et puis quand on nous livre pourquoi on
s'est dit quand il quand on a été
contacté en sont la réflexion en famille
et on s'est dit bon après tout pourquoi
pas tenter l'aventuré et ils ont bien
fait en plus de l'aventuré humaine
ils ont pu faire découvrir une musique
et leur tient à coeur on a évidemment
nos amis de notre entourage et où aller
mais ce qu'on fait il nous a soutenus
mais a surtout eu beaucoup de retours ce
soit en privé ou dans les commentaires
j'ai découvert cette musique c'est un
crois que je connaissais pas là mais
c'est magnifique ce que vous faites donc
vraiment d'avoir fait découvrir cette
musique a essayé plus à des gens c'était
vraiment super content aujourd'hui il
garde un souvenir très positif de la
compétition et de l'entente avec les
autres candidats s'étaient pas une
concurrence où on se bat et entre les
candidats ont sauvegardé comme ça
vraiment il y avait une complicité
c'était vraiment enfin une aventure
vraiment agréable en fait c'était tout à
fait bienveillant on est vraiment des
artistes si on vient pour défendre notre
talent mais avec beaucoup de respect des
uns vers les autres et ça c'est chouette
l'aventuré a commencé en février vient
de s'achever
désormais ils sont reconnus dans la rue
sollicité pour de nombreux projets et
les enfants sont les stars de l'école
quand je suis rentrée dans l'école
mercredi
je suis en train a classé la lingerie
cadier à laruns fait jaser d antonio
navarro moi le lendemain de la finale je
rentre dans ma classe et il ma poésie
tous il se lève tôt qui m'applaudissent
tous gagnés cette émission c'est aussi
remporté 100 mille euros une somme qui
leur sera vraiment utiles je pose en
rival mentionnait que c'est pas la
meilleure période en ce moment ci at on
bien parce que en fait on laboure habité
versa et en une famille nombreuse en
fait en vie dans un petit appartement et
on rentre pas du tout sur la grâce à
cette nouvelle notoriété les projets qui
leur sont proposés il souhaite aussi
aider les autres autant que possible on
va essayer de s'investir avec les moyens
qu'on a
dans des concerts en espérant voilà dans
des actions derrière des associations
qu'on veut soutenir si les codes et
enfants restait la priorité de la
famille des projets devrait se mettre en
place dans les prochains mois